hello everyone and welcome to today's
video on how to set up your digital
marketing agency with $0 so have you
ever thought about starting your own
digital marketing agency but don't have
a big budget well you are in the right
place today we are going to talk about
how you can set up a digital marketing
agency with 0 in 2024 that's right you
don't need a big investment to get
started we'll explore some creative and
practical ways to Kickstart your agency
without breaking the B
so if you are ready to learn how to turn
your passion for digital marketing into
thriving business keep watching also if
you are interested in advancing your
career consider Puro University
post-graduate program in digital
marketing this comprehensive program
offer certification as a digital
marketer through live Interactive
Learning dive deep into fundamentals and
advanced digital marketing strategies
utilizing Harvard Business publishing
cases and Hands-On participation in 20
plus projects access the full spectrum
of digital marketing tools with chat GPT
and AI tools complemented by 35 Plus
dedicated resources so in this video we
will cover what is the role of digital
marketing agency services offered by
digital marketing agencies after that we
will discuss how to set up a digital
marketing agency with 0 so without
further Ado let's start with the first
topic which is what is the role of
digital marketing agency so a digital
marketing agency is like a friendly
guide for businesses navigating the
online world picture them as your trusty
companions in promoting your products or
services on the internet their job is to
make your business Shine by creating
catchy ads making sure your website pops
up when people search for things and
keeping the social media Vibes Lively
they also analyze data to see what's
working and what's not so they can make
changes to improve the results digital
marketing agencies help business connect
with customers in the digital world
where many people spend a lot of their
time they can also help with things like
search engine optimization and email
marketing and creating content like
videos or blog post overall the agency's
job is to help businesses get noticed
and grow their customer base using the
internet all right so this was about
what is the role of digital marketing
agency now let's understand the surfaces
offered by digital marketing agencies so
a digital marketing agency provide a
range of essential services to boost
your online presence and connect with
customers effectively so let's start
with the first one which is web design
or website design so digital marketing
agencies can help create a good-looking
and easy to ous website for your
business now at number two we have
search engine optimization so they can
make sure your website shows up higher
in Google search results so more people
can find it at number three we have web
development so this means they can build
new features for your website or make it
work better so next service is email
marketing so these agencies help you
send out emails to your customers to let
them know about your products and
special offers the next agency would be
social media marketing so these agencies
can manage your business social media
accounts and create posts to get more
people interested in what you are
selling the next is content marketing
this means they can help you create
articles videos or other content to
share online and attract more customer
then at number seven we have payperclick
management so they can help you set up
ads online so that you only pay when
someone clicks on them which can help
bring more people to your website these
are the main services that digital
marketing agencies offer to help
businesses promote themsel online and
reach more customers all right so these
were the services that were offered and
now let's move on to the interesting
part of this video which is how to set
up a digit digital marketing agency with
$0 so the first step here would be start
with market research so market research
is crucial first step for any business
including a digital marketing agency by
understanding your target audience their
needs and the demand for your services
you can tailor your offerings to meet
those needs effectively analyzing your
competitors helps you identify what
makes your agency unique and where you
can stand out in the market to analyze
your existing customer base to
understand their demographics
preferences and needs start with looking
for industry Trends to identify popular
services and emerging demands in the
market the next you can do is conduct
surveys to gather direct feedback from
potential customers about their pain
points and preferences after that you
can develop bias Persona which are
fictional representation of Ideal
customers to better understand and cater
to the needs of your target audience
next you can do is undertake
comprehensive market research to
comprehend your target audience their
pain points and the demand for your
chosen services
next is analyze competitors to identify
Market gaps and opportunities that can
set your agency apart in the digital
marketing landscape all right so these
were the things that you can do in
market research so this was about doing
the market research Next Step would be
address legal requirements yes making
sure your digital marketing agency
follows the rules is super important
when getting started this means
officially setting up your business by
registering it and picking a good name
you have got to do things by the book to
make sure your agency stays on the right
side of the law it's smart to get advice
from legal experts to make sure you're
following all the local rules and also
to create the contracts with your
clients taking care of these legal
things from the beginning helps build a
strong foundation for your agency makes
clients trust you and avoids problems
down the road all right so once you're
done with this then you can go forward
than building a social media presence so
yeah building a social media presence on
platforms like Facebook and Instagram is
really important for businesses these
platforms have lots of people using them
every day so it's good way to reach
potential customers by postponing
interesting and engaging content
business can get people interested in
what they have to offer they can also
use paid advertising on these platforms
to reach even more people this can help
generate leads which means finding the
potential customers who are interested
in what the business is selling by being
active on Facebook and Instagram a
business can build community of people
who like and follow them which can lead
to more sales and stronger connection
with customers so paying attention to
these platforms and building a strong
presence there can really help the
business to grow all right so once you
have started building a social media
presence then you can start with finding
a niche when you're starting in digital
marketing it's good idea to find a
specific area
that you're really good at this would be
things like social media marketing
making websites or helping business to
show up in higher Google searches by
focusing on one of these things you can
become an expert in that area and stand
out from other digital marketers for
example if you're really good at making
websites you can focus on that and
become known for it when businesses need
a new website they will come to you
because they know you are the best at it
the same goes for the other areas like
social media marketing or helping
businesses with their Google ads all
right so this was about finding a niche
now next you can do is create a website
all right so first you can start by
creating a website for your business
this is like having an online store or
office where people can come and learn
about what you do it's a bit of having a
shop on the internet next you can create
a logo of your business a logo is like a
special picture that represents your
business you you can use a free tool
called canva to make a logo that looks
nice and shows what your business is
about after that you can use a free
website builder called vix to actually
make your website vix is like a tool
that helps you put together all the
parts of your website like pictures text
and buttons without needing to know how
to code by doing these things you can
have a nice looking website with a logo
that represents your business and you
can do it all for free this can help
your business look more professional and
make it easier for people to find you
online so once you are done with
creating the website then you can
attract leads with Organic advertising
so attracting leads with Organic
advertising means promoting your
business without paying for ads instead
you use things like social media making
helpful content and improving your
website so that it shows up higher in
the Google searches for example on
social media you can post interesting
things about business that people will
want to share with their friends with
content marketing you can create useful
articles or videos that people will find
the search for things related to your
business and with se you can make sure
your website is set up in a way that
makes it more likely to show up when
people search for things you offer by
using these methods you can attract
people to your business without having
to spend money on ads all right so this
is how you can attract Leaders with
Organic advertising now next step would
be building Networks so building
networks means going to events seminars
and workshops where you can meet people
who might want to use your service or
who work in the same industry as you by
doing this you can make friends with
other businesses and learn about the
newest trends in digital marketing this
can help you find new clients and also
get tips from others in the same line of
work so building network is a good way
to make connections and stay up to date
with what's happening in the digital
marketing world all right so next step
is content marketing so content
marketing is like telling a good story
to people who might be interested in
what you are selling so instead of just
saying buy this you create helpful or
interesting things like articles videos
or pictures that help people want to see
this can make people trust you more and
see you as an expert in what you do it's
like building a strong wall around your
business to protect it and make it all
stand out when you do content marketing
you're not just trying to sell something
right away you're trying to make people
interested in what you do by giving them
something valuable this can bring more
people to your business without you
having to chase after them it's like
making a magnet that pulls customers to
you instead of having to push hard to
get their attention so content marketing
is a smart way to show people that you
know your stuff and to bring more
customers to your business without being
too pushy all right now the next step is
gather feedback so Gathering Fe feedback
is an important part of running a
business it means collecting comments
reviews from your customers to
understand what they like and what could
be proved good firms Yelp and Google my
business are all places where customers
can leave feedback about their
experience with a business good firms is
a platform where business can be
reviewed and red by their customers
helping other people decide if they want
to use that business too Yelp is a
website where people can find a review
find and review to local businesses like
restaurants or shops Google my business
is a tool that lets business manage
their online presence including customer
reviews by gathering feedback on these
platforms business can learn what they
are doing and where they can make
changes to better serve their customers
it's a way for business to listen to
their customers and improve their
products or Services based on what
people are saying these were the steps
to make a digital marketing agency
thanks for turning into today's video on
setting up a digital marketing agency
with $0 in 2024 we hope you found the
information valuable and inspiring
remember with determination and
creativity you can overcome Financial
barriers and make your entrepreneur
dreams reality all right guys with that
we have come to the end of this video If
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up I hope it really help you all
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and sets yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here